today I'm going to be speaking with filmmaker
and journalist Daniel Lumbroso, whose debut
feature, White Noise, is based on his four
years reporting inside the alt right and opened
last year.
Daniel, so great to talk to you today.
Thank you for having me on the show.
So in the film, you spend time with at least
some folks that I know to some degree.
I've interviewed Richard Spencer a few years
ago, and it was sort of an interesting experience,
which we can talk about.
I mean, I guess first to kind of set the stage,
what was the goal here?
How did you get into covering the alt?
Right.
And how did you end up basically meeting a
lot of these people and spending time with
them?
So I was one of the first reporters in the
country to start covering the right right
around when actually you were putting out
these really important primers on the movement.
And I was watching them at the time.
If you go back to twenty sixteen, when Trump
was a candidate, the movement was not getting
a lot of attention.
And I was a young reporter at the Atlantic
at the time.
And, you know, I just said to my editors,
like, there is this fiercely anti-Semitic,
racist movement that's bubbling up online
at the time on Reddit and obviously 4chan
as well.
I had only graduated from college a few years
earlier, so I saw know aspects of that on
college campuses already.
And I just said to the editor of The Atlantic,
this is something we have to pay attention
to.
It's only growing in strength.
A few months later, I started covering Richard
Spencer before he was a household name, and
I was the one who actually caught a roomful
of people breaking out into Nazi salutes.
You might remember that viral video at the
time.
Yep.
And that was really important because it clarified
that this wasn't just a group of edgy conservatives
like the way it was covered.
And I think you also did a great job of clarifying
that at the time.
This was fundamentally a white nationalist
movement and it needed to be covered with
the utmost due diligence and care.
When Charlottesville happened about eight
months later, the Atlantic understood that
this was only growing in strength and they
gave me the space to to produce a feature
film.
So that's when it really became a full time
project.
When you look at your time spent with these
folks and I know I know you've covered Richard
Spencer, you've covered Mike Synovate, you've
covered Lauren Southern and and many others
there.
I'm curious your thoughts on whether we can
make any more general assessments of the goals
of these folks, because to some degree, I
feel like many of them recognize that their
goals, at least as stated, are not likely
to become a reality any time soon.
And so that leads me to wonder about whether
this is essentially a marketing of some kind.
Marketing themselves presents essentially
becoming known within a movement and less
less about actually achieving the movement's
goals or whether or whatever.
I mean, I guess that's that's I'll leave it
there.
It's a great question, I mean, it really runs
the gamut.
I think fundamentally this is a violent movement.
Richard Spencer, who coined the term.
All right.
He believes in a wide ethno state.
What that might sound like a flashy word,
but what it means is a country that has, let's
say, 90 percent white population.
The US is sixty three percent white and declining
every year.
I think that's great.
We should not that we cheer for that, but
it's great to have a multicultural country
where everyone gets along, you know, to get
to the 90 percent white ethnic state.
We're talking about mass deportations.
We're talking about ethnic cleansing.
Those are fundamentally racist ideas.
But then you get the other side of it.
And white noise really is all about the spectrum
of the right and how it goes.
All the GRIF tourism, that's part of it.
You get a guy like Mike Synovate who, you
know, is happy to benefit from the racism
and how it can help you build a brand.
And you see over the course of the film that
he's selling skin care products, he's selling
pills, he's making money off of big parties
and some crappy bar in New York City.
There is there is so much about it.
That's opportunism.
It's celebrity, it's vanity.
So the motivations are mixed.
And I think that's why people are having a
lot of having trouble sometimes making sense
of what happened Wednesday.
They're saying, is this serious or is it laughing?
It can be both.
And I found that it was both.
Yeah.
I mean, it seems like in a country of three
hundred and thirty one million, there's plenty
of room for all of the above to be examples
of it and to still have plenty of everything.
Exactly, and I think what needs to be clear,
though, is that even if you're coming from
it as someone who's laughing, who's playing,
who's having their moment in the sun, you're
still adjusting yourself to the Spencers,
to the Oath Keepers, to these people who believe
this is a white man's country.
And I think that's morally problematic.
And maybe that will get you some more Twitter
followers and some money.
But it's not worth the coalition that you're
in.
One of the things that's come up in the days
since the January 6th, riotous insurrection
is some even people I respect, like, for example,
economist Richard Wolffe, who was my college
professor and others have been sort of reducing
what took place last week to economic oppression
and the natural result of inequality.
And I respect a lot of the folks that are
saying this, but I think that these are sort
of some of their less good takes.
And I did a commentary about it earlier on
in today's program.
I'm curious because you you were in and observing
a lot of these movements.
What can we say about the degree to which
economic oppression plays a role?
Not for people like Spencer, who I believe
is from a wealthy family individually, but
in the people that followed these movements.
To what degree could it be that economic oppression
is what makes them liable to get sucked in,
but is not really the focus of the activism?
Or what can we say about the economic aspect?
I think the economic anxiety argument is nonsense.
No offense to the professor, I mean, most
of the people that I covered from upper middle
class, highly, highly educated, they live
in New York, D.C., Los Angeles.
All the scenes in my film take place in liberal
enclaves, San Francisco, Southern California,
D.C., many others.
I mean, that's where these movements have
strength.
And, of course, they may attract footsoldiers
from Alabama and whatever, but this is not
like your grandaddy's racism.
People in you know, in trailer parks like
burning crosses.
And of course, there's some of that iconography.
But this is the leaders down to the followers
are really like smart, educated kids who have
been radicalized by these ideas.
And you ask about how it happens.
It's not because they're hit with high taxes
and they feel like it's it's tyrannical and
they just want a more libertarian state.
Maybe there are a few of those people I met,
very few of them.
What it really is, is that these people are
selling you on a promise that you might be
a bored, unemployed kid in your mom's basement,
but you're actually a descendant of a crusader,
of a Greek, of a Roman that you could take
part in this amazing historical legacy.
And I think that's a really intoxicating narrative
to see that you're not just, you know, a disaffected
kid with no sense of purpose in the world.
You could take part in something larger.
And that's what they're really appealing to,
is a sense of narrative, kind of the sense
of purpose, existential purpose.
Well, when I when I've interviewed former
KKK neo-Nazi types, Frank Mink and Scott Shepard
and, you know, a lot of these different interesting
people and those who have spent time with
them, folks like Daryl Davis as an example,
the thing that invariably comes up is that
they were pulled into these movements from
a very particular circumstance, which almost
always is lack of connection to other people,
often parents, but not necessarily feeling
out of touch with anything that they would
call community.
Sometimes there's abuse, psychological or
physical, that's going on.
And for the most part, they will they will
recognize these are the ones that made it
out.
Right.
So it's a self-selecting group, but they will
recognize that the ideology could have almost
been anything from whoever kind of presented
them with empathy and connection in a place
where they could belong.
Can you talk about that a little bit in the
experiences you've had researching and doing
the film?
It's a great point.
I mean, when you're inside the movement, it
feels like a subculture that could be any
kind of subculture.
It's almost like they're Internet celebrities
who happen to be racist.
And of course, the racism is important.
But what you notice immediately is, is the
commonalities, the code of communication.
They all dress the same 20th century like
Hitler Youth style haircuts.
Many of Richard Spencer's followers wear short
shorts and they're all drinking the same drinks
like whiskey.
They're all eating the same foods.
There's all of these ingroup jokes.
I mean, it's really a community.
It's a cult like any other.
And I've done a lot of embedded reporting
and other types of fundamentalist movements,
but any any sort of community.
And it resembles any sort of tight knit community
where the community is conferring importance
onto the followers, giving them a sense of
purpose in the world.
And I think if you track it to the individual,
all of them have a sense of resentment.
They feel like they haven't been given their
due in the world.
So like Smirnova, which was an out of work
lawyer, his first wife was very successful.
She's a she's a lawyer at several big tech
companies.
And they got divorced.
He took a lot of her money and took a lot
of money and alimony, which is very, you know,
Beita for the so-called alpha male.
And he felt really resentful that he never
really took off as a lawyer.
And then he found a niche in this world.
He became someone prestigious on the far right,
you know, mainstreaming everything from pizza,
gay to that.
Hillary had Parkinson's.
He became a person of status.
And I think that's what this can provide.
And the list goes on and on.
Richard Spencer was in and out of work.
Journalist never got any attention.
And then one day Trump ran was the gasoline
that Spencer needed to start the engine.
And all of them, especially the leadership,
share that kind of story where the movement
gave them I gave them a purpose in the world.
Not that this was the most important thing
you just said, but it just kind of piqued
my curiosity.
You say they eat the same foods.
What foods are they eating?
That that's that's interesting.
You know, there's that there is a few funny
examples.
Lawrence Sutherland, who's one of the three
characters in the film and I think probably
the most interesting her has her her boyfriend
at the time.
They've now broken up.
We joked with a culinary white supremacist
because he told me he refused to eat, quote,
non European foods.
Really?
So I went I filmed them on a date once and
he wouldn't touch the ketchup because he claimed
ketchup was originally derived from China,
from the word ketchup or something.
So he wouldn't touch the ketchup.
And we ate it like a British pub in Toronto.
They ate.
It's in the film.
And it's also in an article I wrote about
Lauren and that section of the story when.
Totally viral on Twitter because it's just
absurd.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Like, I wonder, is brisket considered white,
Russian or Jewish, like wood brisket be acceptable?
I wonder where they would come down on that.
Well, Jews are not part of the ethnic state.
Right.
I'm Jewish.
And I was on a road trip with with Spencer
to one of his shoots.
And the car broke down once.
And we were stuck in central Florida and pitch
black at a gas station for a few hours.
And I said, Richard, like, can I be a part
of your ethnic state?
And he was like, I'm sorry, Daniel, but it's
not going to work.
Well, it's interesting you mention that, because
when I had him on, there was this question
of sort of like, you know, a lot of this idea
of the ethno state is based on some fundamental
incompatibility of these groups that just
like we can kind of pretend to get along.
And he said you and I could probably get together
and have a beer and there would not be an
obvious conflict in that particular interaction.
But at some bigger picture level, there's
differences in values, there's differences
in culture, et cetera.
And and I don't know if he this interview
was three and a half years ago.
I don't know if it's he or others of his ilk
who have said that when Jews appear to be
integrated into American culture, it's because
they've essentially given up whatever is core
to them and are kind of adopting the American
thing.
And there's kind of these post hoc explanations.
But you actually did the thing like you hung
around for a while.
Yeah, and I think what happens if I'm Jewish,
I'm also the grandson of two Holocaust survivors,
and over time I would tell my subjects about
their terrible stories, you know, losing most
of their families.
You know, I think everyone makes exceptions
for people they like.
And the honest truth is that they came to
like me.
They would text me and vulnerable moments.
A lot of that that stuff that was on the record
is in the story I wrote about Lauren.
You know, they would make exceptions.
But the truth is, is that, like the Jew is
and always has been a stand in for any sort
of issue that we see in society.
So now they're the bankers.
Soros, obviously, is something we use all
the time.
He's the image of the parasite who's pulling
the strings from behind the scenes.
You know, it's very common to hear them talk
about the Rothschilds use to talk about the
Zionist occupied government, which really
isn't anything about Israel.
It's actually saying that the US is and is
occupied by Jews behind the scenes.
And, you know, I think there's so much dog
whistles, anti anti-Semitism that's all around
in this movement.
Some of them don't even realize that they're
purveying it and others are actively doing
it.
And when it comes to the state, they're very,
very clear that that this might come as a
surprise to most Americans, but that Jews
don't count as white in far right contexts.
Historically in Europe, Jews were not considered
white.
They were the original other, of course.
And yeah.
And Richard, to achieve his dream, is willing
to accept any kind of white person that wouldn't
have historically been seen white just because
he needs numbers.
So he'll take Russia and he'll take Southern
Italians.
All the undesirables of the past are fine.
Right.
But Jews, because of their unique history,
would not be part of it in the limited time
we have left.
Based on all of your work and knowledge and
experience, we're wondering once Trump goes,
a lot of these folks that seem to have only
gotten involved in politics because of Trump
and don't really care about policy, they're
not really conservatives in the traditional
sense.
Do they remain engaged?
Do they mostly go back to being apolitical
the way they were before Trump?
I think they remain engaged and the reason
is this, there's a huge market opportunity
for these ideas there.
There are millions of people who believe them
stop this deal.
The hashtag around that the election was supposedly
stolen from Trump.
It's completely untrue.
People are bringing in hundreds of thousands
or even millions of dollars behind that fraudulent
idea.
There are many individuals I'm not going to
call them out by name who have made a lot
of money from that that lie in many other
lies.
The market opportunity will remain because
there are millions of resentful people that
believe that this is a white man's country
and believe that President Trump was wrongfully
terminated by a bunch of liberals and Jews
and Democrats.
And as long as there is a base that's willing
to eat up and pay for those ideas, the individuals
will still be there ready to hock them and
make money off them.
All right.
We've been speaking with Daniel Lombroso.
The film is White Noise.
What are all the places where people can find
the film, Daniel?
It's on Amazon Prime.
It's also on iTunes.
And we're doing a global educational tour.
So if you're interested in having a dialog
around the film, you can reach out to me as
well.
Thanks, Daniel.
I really appreciate you telling us about it
today.
Thanks so much for having me.
That was great.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.